après le tumulte de l'hémicycle les
députés on te reprit le chemin de leur
circonscription mais ce n'est pas
toujours plus apaisé ceux de la majorité
présidentielle doivent maintenant
assurer le service après-vente d'une
réforme impopulaire adoptée aux 49-3
exemple avec le député Loir-et-Chérien
Christophe Marion qui a suivi Faustine
lune
je suis dans ma ville ici quand même
première sortie sur le marché de Vendôme
pour Christophe Marion depuis l'adoption
de la réforme des retraites par 49.3
lundi ce député de la majorité
présidentielle n'a pas voté la motion de
censure et ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde bonjour on n'est pas très copain
je sais j'imagine bien j'imagine bien
bonjour mais enfin vous voyez on a beau
ne pas être copain moi je sers la main à
tout le monde
là vous êtes en train de faire le lit de
du Front National et c'est super
évidemment pas une seconde j'ai envisagé
de voter la motion de censure d'une part
parce que
je pense que cette réforme des retraites
elle est nécessaire je pense que la
politique menée par le Président de la
République est bonne j'ai juste un souci
avec ce point de méthode qui à mon avis
aurait pu être évité cette méthode le
49-3 c'est ce qui lui pose problème
surtout pour un sujet comme les
retraites pris très à coeur par la
population c'est vrai que le 49-3 a créé
une vraie tension
moi j'aurais préféré qu'on aille au vote
c'est pas une question de démocratie ou
non démocratie le 49 francs il est prévu
dans notre Constitution maintenant il y
a des sujets de tension extrême dans
notre pays et là il me semble que nous
devons faire preuve de et bien d'un peu
plus de mesures dans l'utilisation des
outils constitutionnels et donc nous
devons absolument renouer le lien avec
nos concitoyens pour Christophe Marion
il s'agit du premier sujet si épineux
depuis son arrivée à l'Assemblée
nationale en 2022 sa circonscription
aussi n'a pas été épargnée par les
manifestations ce jeudi entre 2500 et
3000 personnes ont défilé dans les rues
de Vendôme